you're making extra money I'm gonna pay
you more than I paid anybody yeah okay
so solo the last time we spoke you your
name was Kristen but I understand you're
just your name changes clearly by the
day no from a cop you know exactly so uh
tell me what's been going on since the
last time we spoke there was about a
year ago okay um well I'm still
prostituting well I was until recently
but yeah I'm prostituting and I'm still
smoking crack you know I'm still living
on the streets still homeless but
outside of that like recently I've been
in the hospital so what happened with
your eye you got yeah yeah well one of
my dates I got kidnapped and tortured
and raped and held hostage for like two
and a half three days I don't know I got
into a car and and the guy was like a
normal date you know I'm saying I wasn't
early tripping on he one no scary man he
wasn't off freaky or nothing like that
he was just more like you know average I
don't know he just looked average but
the guy whatever was you know I was
smoking a cigarette I'm looking out the
window
what white black I'm he was Mexican
Mexican yeah and like I was smoking a
cigarette looking out the window and the
guy like put something over my face and
the only thing I remember is like I kind
of jumped back to like seeing his hand
comment right but I knocked out
completely like within seconds I'm
guessing like just I was out I don't
remember nothing I didn't see nothing um
whenever I came to like it was just
really weird where I was at it looked at
like metal walls maybe like I was in a
freight train or like a storage place I
don't really know or maybe his basement
if he had metal up or I don't know where
you were no but it was like really long
it was a long place and there was
nothing in there but a pallet and then
he had a cooler in there you know and
that's all that I could see cuz it was
really dark and um and so the guy like
throughout the time that we was there I
kept coming in and out like knocking out
or whatever
and but I was up for a period of time
and when I was he was just like really
weird he was like telling me um you know
oh you and make a great wife and you're
my bride-to-be and you would like that
wouldn't you and like if I if I shook my
head no then he would like beat on me
and hit me you know and he kept raping
me and then here you go like really
really mean like saying you cheated on
me [ __ ] - hi weird [ __ ] you know I'm
like New England so you should go from
nice to abuse it back and forth yeah and
I mean like he would do that for like
two or three hours though I'm just like
really nice and like hitting my head and
oh let me wash you up and I mean just
really weird stuff right and then he'd
be like I'm sorry I hurt you but you've
hurt me so bad and like I don't know
this guy at all at all you never better
before never never ever and I don't even
date Mexican guys sorry no that's like I
don't stay dumb in my normal life you
know so so I was like what the [ __ ] is
going on you know and so I thought that
the guy was gonna kill me really like I
didn't even think that I was gonna make
it and I had I guess from trauma I
knocked out for several hours
I don't know whenever I came back - he
wasn't there so like of course you know
like anybody else I was trying to get
away like I was trying to get my hands
out and I'm like you know and from me I
guess struggling enough I pass back out
I went back to sleep how many days was
this two and a half three days it was
like you know right at 3 days a couple
hours from 3 days but yeah like I was I
remember I was doing this and this with
my feet and I'm like you know on the
[ __ ] movie this [ __ ] alright I hate
that work anybody you know and I was
like trying everything in my mouth of
escape so I couldn't fight it or nothing
and there was nothing like around me but
I couldn't even move that far he had me
like pinned like on my back he had a
thing hooked onto my like the pants that
he put on he had a buckle and like he
had a hooked onto something on the floor
so I couldn't even
like so I'm like how the [ __ ] my head
and I can't put my hands behind me or
nothing you know but I could fill it on
my back like and I'm like what the hell
and I could hear the chain when I would
move what I could a little bit that I
couldn't move you know and so when he
came when I woke back up he was there
and the guy was like he had a bow and
he's like you know a sponge and he's all
like oh I'm gonna wash you up and don't
worry it's all gonna be over soon and
you know you should really know that
there's bad people in the world and yeah
and that is not safe out there for you
to do this my sister at one time got
killed by again I mean it was a weird
were you really in fear of your life at
some point yeah like I thought I was she
was gonna murder me he had a duffel bag
and a [ __ ] spy so I'm sitting there
and he's like telling me my sister was a
prostitute got killed like you know and
I mean it was a real like just mental
psychological like you're you know what
I'm saying the whole event and he's like
it's just gonna be over soon he's like
washed at me and he's like this ain't
gonna hurt and he put that thing over my
mouth on my nose right and I knocked
back out I thought that he was gonna
kill me yeah you know like that was it
because he kept saying it's over now and
you know and it's been a good marriage
and oh really
yeah but I gotta let you go and I'm like
you know you got to go to your final
destination like the rest of us and it
was just weird he was a weirdo you know
and I'm like yo so when I woke up a man
that was jogging out in West LA had
actually was jogging and seen me and I
was laying half on the grass and half on
the cement but I had blood and I was
naked from the bottom down and I had
blood on my on my face and there's blood
on the cement where my head was
and I was naked from here down and I had
bruises and stuff I learned me so the
guy was like waking me up he had his
cellphone on him and whenever I came to
I was like what the you know and I
jerked away from him and I'm like don't
touch me right and I noticed that my
mouth was
and that was the first thing and then I
jumped up and I was like kind of you
know like nervous I'm shaking real bad
he was like are you okay are you okay
you want me to call the police no it's
just like nah you know don't call the
police you know because it most time
don't work out in our favor and I don't
do that and so he was like okay you know
are you sure you're okay and I said yeah
I just had an incident you know and I'm
okay I'm okay and so he was like are you
sure and I took off real quick because I
didn't want him to call the police and
um and I ran into by the CBS and the CBS
the guy that works at the CBS over there
actually gave me a pair of sweats to put
on oh good yeah cuz I was just like look
I'm a prostitute
and I just got raped the guy kept my
pants you know and he was like okay you
know come here come here and he took me
to the back and get me a pair of pants
which was really nice of him then I left
from there I went to USC Medical are you
UCLA medical right there at the hospital
and I was pretty beat up and I they said
that I had been raped multiple times I
also suffered from trauma they had me
there for almost a week
I just got out two days ago oh geez yeah
so has this has this changed your your
attitude about what you do for a living
and living on the street and all that
well clearly my husband changes I did
but huh no it's pretty scary and I think
right now like if I do go back into that
like it would only be with my regulars
the people that I've known for years
because that kind of freaked me out
it's like you can just get into a car
and I never I never thought it on that
guy like I never seen it come in and
usually I'm pretty good with like you
know picking up on people
cuz I'll jump out of the car in a minute
I'm like I'm good but uh from past
experiences but I didn't see it coming
at all you know usually as a woman you
get that feeling like this probably
ain't the best situation you know so
maybe I should get out especially doing
what we do out here
you become very aware I've been doing
for several years so you become very
aware and you learn people's body
language you learn their mannerism you
know Anna you become really good at that
how many years have you been out um I've
been doing this for I'm gonna say 1415
years yeah
and so um of course you know you go
through different things which helps you
to learn that to have that experience
your intuition probably gets very very
good very good
yeah and I didn't see it coming you know
so that's that's really hard to deal
with and not to mention I mean the guy
he had kids there was a car seat in the
back oh jeez yeah yeah which also made
me feel a little more comfortable you
know with the whole situation cuz I'm
like I always got kids he's a family man
what do you bring on you know then think
nothing of it nothing at all
and out of nowhere it was just happy I'm
so glad you're okay
thank you Thanks don't be a horrible
yeah survivor hey I'm glad you're I'm
glad you're back with us thank you and
be careful out there oh well did you
have you told any of your family or
anybody that yeah yeah come I think was
very actually you know I sister was just
like what the hell come home and I'm
like no you know but I mean they're so
my family is very like how do I put it
like backward they don't they're not
knowledgeable really about here yeah so
like just this should I tell them period
like I smoked crack on the streets they
don't get it they're like what and I'm
like yeah we just light of our pipe like
in front of the jail don't flirt wisely
yeah I learned like what do because - I
said they wave at us they're more likely
to bust a jaywalker you know so my
family they don't they don't get it
really and I don't know it they want me
to come home but I tell them like you
know it ain't nothing unusual like I've
been raped before you guys know that
things I made it through it was pretty
traumatic as far as you know my sleeping
and different things but I think I'll be
okay on me I'm always looking at the
bright side of things so you know I've
been calling the cops on this guy you
have no identifying um no but pretty
much how it works over there is if I see
him come back to Agatha which most of
the time the Predators do come back
right which is really crazy and stupid
but they actually return to where they
initially get their victims right and uh
and so if he comes back how pretty much
will work is a girl will lure him and
he'll get grabbed out the car beat up
and [ __ ] up severely was it right and
if the right person gets hold on he may
not come back yeah interesting yeah you
know Skid Row yeah all your dreams come
through all right so thank you so much
for telling me the story it's more all
right
I'm glad you came glad you survived it
thank you all right all right
you